Shazam's 21st century adventure on the big
screen is an origin story, so don't worry
too much if you're going in cold.
Just make sure you're paying attention and
enjoy the ride.
But even if you aren't familiar with the characters,
you're certainly going to see a few familiar
faces bringing them to life.
Here's why the cast of Shazam! looks so familiar.
Oh, and just in case you haven't seen the
movie yet?
Spoilers ahead.
Seeing as he's playing the supersized version
of young Billy Batson otherwise known as Shazam
Zachary Levi is essentially the face of the
film, and probably the most recognizable face
all around.
"I'd like to purchase some of your finest
beer, please."
With any luck, Shazam! will give the supremely
talented Levi that final push onto the Hollywood
A-list.
Wondering where you've seen him before?
Well, Shazam! is hardly Levi's first superhero
flick.
The actor last suited up for cosmic action
as Fandral alongside his fellow Warriors Three
in Thor: The Dark World and Thor: Ragnarok.
It's far more likely that you recognize Levi
from his extensive work on the small screen.
Most recently, he appeared in the short-lived
series Heroes Reborn, and starred in the cheeky
NBC sitcom Telenovela.
He also impressed with a serious turn in Netflix's
marvelous dramatic mini-series Alias Grace.
Of course, Levi is probably best known for
his work on NBC's awesome, oft-overlooked
action/dramedy Chuck.
The actor brought some serious geek energy
to his charming portrayal of a directionless
post-grad who inadvertently downloads a secretive
government computer program into his brain.
And yes, it's every bit as fun as it looks.
Shazam! could also prove the first big break
for the actor portraying Billy Batson, the
pint-sized version of Levi's superhero.
"Are you for real?"
"Say it!"
"Okay!"
We're guessing that most of you don't know
who Asher Angel is, because he's just getting
started in showbiz.
Some of you may recognize the youngster from
his one-off role in the short-lived spin-off
series Criminal Minds: Beyond Borders.
A few of you might also have even seen Angel
as the second lead in the 2018 ballet drama
Driven to Dance.
If not, those of you with the Disney Channel
might just recognize Angel as the conspicuously
kind-hearted Jonah Beck from the family-friendly
comedy Andi Mack.
Whether you're familiar with Angel's work
yet or not, we're fairly confident you'll
be seeing his face a lot moving forward possibly
even in a Shazam! sequel!
The actor playing his precocious, crutch-bound
best pal Freddie Freeman has been on the Hollywood
radar for few years now.
"Dude, just messing around.
You look at me and you're like, 'Why so dark?
You're a disabled foster kid.
You've got it all!"
His name is Jack Dylan Grazer, and he got
his first taste of stardom with a brief appearance
in 2015's chilling horror anthology Tales
of Halloween.
He followed that family-friendly outing with
a starring role in the TV series Me, Myself
and I, a comedy exploring key moments in a
man's life over three distinct time periods,
with Grazer portraying the youngest version
of the protagonist.
The up-and-coming actor went from relative
unknown to impressive newcomer when he joined
the Losers Club as the nervous, overprotected
Eddie Kaspbrak in the brilliant adaptation
of Stephen King's It — a role Grazer is
ready to reprise in 2019's hotly-anticipated
sequel.
In between those horrifying blockbusters,
Grazer also booked the prime gig of playing
the adolescent version of Timothee Chalamet's
character in the indie hit Beautiful Boy.
Grace Fulton is likely to be familiar to quite
a few viewers.
Fulton portrays Billy and Freddie's foster
sister Mary Bromfield in Shazam!, and much
like her co-star Jack Dylan Grazer in It,
Fulton has likewise played the younger version
of a character in a film.
In fact, one of Fulton's biggest early roles
came as the adolescent version of ill-fated
Hollywood starlet Natalie Wood in the 2004
TV movie The Mystery of Natalie Wood.
She followed that role with a recurring gig
as the younger version of Jennifer Love Hewitt's
Melinda Gordon in The Ghost Whisperer.
Later, she booked a multi-episode gig as the
teenage counterpart to Madeleine Stowe's matriarch
on ABC's Revenge.
Of course, most viewers will recognize Fulton
as one the eldest of the tormented orphans
in 2017's chilling addition to the Conjuring
universe, Annabelle: Creation.
Shazam! finds Djimon Hounsou playing an ancient
wizard who gives Billy Batson the power to
transform into Shazam.
Hounsou spent the early years of his career
as a fashion model and backup dancer in music
videos for Tina Turner and Janet Jackson,
among many others.
Steven Spielberg used his own wizardry to
pull a heartrending breakout performance from
the model-turned-actor in 1997's Amistad.
The film made an overnight star out of Hounsou,
who has gone on to appear in dozens of films,
including memorable turns in Ridley Scott's'
Gladiator, the heartrending 2002 drama In
America, and the fast-paced 2015 action film
Furious 7, even earning a few Oscar nominations
in the process.
If you're wondering where you've seen Hounsou
recently, it was likely in the MCU, where
the actor portrayed the Kree warrior Korath
in both Guardians of the Galaxy and Captain
Marvel.
Speaking of Shazam! actors who have superhero
experience, let's not forget about the great
Mark Strong.
The iron-jawed actor plays the nefarious Dr.
Thaddeus Sivana in this latest DC flick, but
Shazam! is far from Strong's first turn as
a super-baddie.
He actually played another DC villain almost
a decade ago in that oh-so-forgettable Ryan
Reynolds-starring Green Lantern.
Of course, Strong may just have a face for
villainy, because he broke bad again as the
vile Frank D'Amico in 2010's Kick-Ass.
Strong also played memorable villains in the
big screen adaptation of Neil Gaiman's Stardust.
“ahhh”
And try not to forget the 2009, Robert Downey
Jr.-starring Sherlock Holmes, where he played
the evil Lord Blackwood.
Did you happen to catch his performance in
Ridley Scott's Robin Hood, where he played
Godfrey?
Rest assured, the role of the bad guy in Shazam!
is in the hands of an extremely good actor.
He's also starred in the Kingsman movies,
the 2008 thriller Body of Lies, Zero Dark
Thirty, and countless other films.
The actor playing the adult version of Freddy
Freeman will likely need no introduction.
Adam Brody did, after all, get his first big
break with a multi-episode stint as would-be
rocker Dave in Gilmore Girls.
His follow-up role as the ever-nerdy Seth
Cohen on The O.C. helped the young actor achieve
full-on teen heartthrob status.
"I'm sorry if I'm the only one here who will
state the obvious."
"Seth—"
"but we have all this extra room, right?
We have a pool house."
Brody has also made scene-stealing appearances
in movies like the 2014 coming of age drama
Growing Up And Other Lies, Wes Craven's meta-horror
sequel Scream 4, and Whit Stillman's Damsels
in Distress.
Dyed-in-wool horror fans will most likely
recognize Brody for his disturbing and hilarious
turn as an indie-rocker with some serious
ulterior motives in the bloody Diablo Cody
satire Jennifer's Body.
Freddie Freeman isn't the only one of Shazam's
pint-sized pals to get a superhero alter ego
in the movie.
In fact, most of Billy's foster fam earn spots
in the super-powered "Shazam Family."
The inimitable Meagan Good scored the role
of the adult Darla Dudley, who undergoes a
truly radical transformation throughout the
course of the film.
If you're wondering where you've seen her
before, take your pick, 'cause she's been
cranking out movies on the regular since breaking
into showbiz in the mid-'90s.
Of her work in that bygone decade, most will
recognize Good as the confused big sis in
the coming-of-age drama Eve's Bayou.
In the years since, Good has racked up memorable
roles in TV shows like Californication, and
the sadly short-lived Minority Report series.
She's also nursed a booming big screen career
that's seen her appear in films like Anchorman
2: The Legend Continues and the entirely unfortunate
2008 comedy The Love Guru.
"And now, I'd like to show my love by making
for you the Quebec pizza."
"What's that?"
"Pop Tart with the ketchup."
And don't forget you bloodcurdling work in
the horrific and outright horrible Saw 5.
Here's hoping Shazam! helps make a household
name of Good.
Of the actors playing adult, super-powered
versions of younger characters in Shazam!,
Michelle Borth isn't one of the better-known
names.
Still, that doesn't mean you won't recognize
the face of the future Mary Marvel or Lady
Shazam or just plain ole Mary, AKA Mary Bromfield.
Though Borth has yet to find a legitimate
breakthrough role in Hollywood, she's been
in the game for a couple of decades now.
Hawk-eyed viewers might recognize Borth for
a one-off appearance as Dean's significant
other in a trippy episode of Supernatural.
Or perhaps you caught her in HBO's relationship
drama Tell Me You Love Me.
Odds are most of you know Borth from her 60-episode
run as Catherine Rollins on Hawaii Five-O.
And if you don't know Michelle Borth from
any of those projects, now's as good a time
as any to learn her name, because you'll be
hearing it for years to come.
Just a few years ago, most viewers would not
have been able to pick actor Ross Butler out
of a lineup even if his 6'2" frame unquestionably
set him apart from most of his peers.
While viewers still may not have Butler's
name memorized, it's a safe bet they'll recognize
his face from one of several notable small
screen appearances over the past few years.
The actor first started turning heads in 2015
when he appeared in Disney Channel's action
comedy K.C.
Undercover.
That same year, Butler booked one of his highest-profile
gigs when he claimed the role of tough-guy
jock Reggie Mantle in The CW's surprise hit
Riverdale.
With an obvious penchant for teen drama, Butler
again played a tough-guy jock with a conscience
in Netflix's teen suicide drama 13 Reasons
Why.
Though he's yet to find his breakout role,
Ross Butler is very much a star on the rise,
and there's little doubt that his work as
the superpowered adult version of Eugene Choi
will set his star a little bit higher.
The actor playing the father of Shazam! baddie
Dr. Sivana will need no introduction to fans
of the superhero genre the DC Universe in
particular.
The actor's name is John Glover, known for
his giddily wicked work as Lionel Luther on
the long-running "Superman in high school"
drama Smallville.
In addition to his voice work as the Riddler
in Batman: The Animated Series, fans of the
Dark Knight should also recall Glover's face
for his appearance as the mad scientist Dr.
Jason Woodrue in 1997's Batman & Robin.
Love it or hate it, Glover's maniacally over-the-top
performance was unquestionably one of the
best parts of Joel Schumacher's controversial
farce.
If you managed to miss Glover in those super-powered
flicks, you'll probably still recognize his
face.
He's a beloved character actor who's been
working steadily in showbiz since the '70s.
Among Glover's more memorable roles are appearances
in the Oscar-winning dramedy Annie Hall.
"You know how I'd like to die?"
"No, how?"
"I'd like to be torn apart by wild animals."
And let's not forget his stupendously scene-stealing
work opposite Bill Murray in 1988's Scrooged.
Oh, and then there was his equally delicious
role in the 1990 sci-fi sequel, RoboCop 2.
"Magno-volt!
The final word in auto security."
That's to say nothing of his memorably hilarious
turn as the head of the Clamp Cable Network
in the cult classic Gremlins 2: The New Batch.
There's plenty of other roles worth mentioning,
like his part in John Carpenter's unheralded
masterpiece In the Mouth of Madness.
All we really want to say about John Glover
is that he's one of those actors who makes
us smile the second he turns up on screen.
Check out one of our newest videos right here.
Plus, even more exclusive Looper videos about
your favorite films are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.